let's talk about the House and Senate
it's a disaster in both I'll show you a
map here of the results that we have the
Republicans have won not only the White
House but with Donald Trump in addition
to with Donald Trump winning the White
House they've won the house as well as
the Senate we will start with the Senate
here is a list of key races where the
incumbent didn't win right that's what
we're sort of interested in in
California
Kamel harris defeated Loretta Sanchez by
nearly a two-to-one ratio that's the
Democrat in Nevada Democrat Katherine
Cortes Masto narrowly defeated the
Republican Joe heck in Illinois Tammy
Duckworth a Democrat defeated Mark Kirk
that is good news now in Indiana total
disaster evan bay me or does he say by I
don't remember even by the Democrat lost
to Republican Todd young in Maryland
good news were chris van hollen defeated
Republican Cathy's illega and as of now
still too close to call New Hampshire
Maggie Hassan the Democrat slightly
ahead of Kelly Ayotte the incumbent
Republican but that is still too close
to call we will hopefully know about
that soon now without knowing the New
Hampshire results we know that
Republicans so far have gained one seat
and we can very quickly and easily take
a look at the house results they don't
look good I've got a map to show you and
the house situation is not looking good
at all 238 Republicans to 191 Democrats
there's still a few districts there
which you might be able to see in
Louisiana which as of right now have not
been called a couple in California that
have not been called of one in Nebraska
I believe which maybe now has been
called total and utter disaster later on
you know we we this today November 9
2016 today is the day for progressives
to make the plan as to how to go forward
and we're all going to talk about that
guys a little bit later in the show but
gerrymandering and the 2020 census are
two words or I guess three two words and
a number call it what you want a phrase
that the progressives that want change
need to become very well acquainted with
form for the plan I'm going to lay out
Pat and we knew that the house wasn't
go democratic yeah this time around even
though we were a bit hopeful about it a
few weeks ago yeah but the Senate was
totally up for grabs and it seems like
the Republicans who stuck with Trump
actually did better and you see Joe heck
lost his race Kelly Ayotte is losing her
race and those are the people who
defected from Trump the power of Trump
Rachel who would have thought yeah it's
a quite maddening and I I feel like it
kind of became clear to me and I know
we've talked about this in the past why
certain Republicans were choosing not to
kind of denounce Donald Trump because
they did not want to kind of marginalize
any of their followers and the ones that
stayed true to that it worked for them
it did absolutely work and that is
absolutely surprising and we're going to
see what ultimately happens House Senate
white house for the Republicans the
future of America we'll talk about what
to do later today's program is made
possible in part by Omaha Steaks and the
Omaha Steaks family grill pack which I
have been working my way through some of
what you get includes filet mignon
top sirloin all beef meatballs these
steak burgers and much much more you can
go to Omaha Steaks com and in the search
bar you put in Packman PA que ma n
that's my last name by the way if some
of you are like what show am i watching
right now I have no idea how I got here
yes Pakman is my last name PA que ma N
and then you will see the family grill
pack which you can add to your cart for
the discounted rate of $49.99 I've
converted my across-the-hall neighbor
Roger into the Omaha Steaks world by
sharing with him because I like to share
I said hey I've got these Omaha Steaks
why don't we grill this evening on the
roof deck it is getting cold in Boston
but we had one or two warm days where we
were able to get some grilling done and
it's absolutely fantastic my favorite is
the filet mignon Rogers was not he liked
basically every other item he's just a
big big top sirloin guy and all of the
other stuff that came with it
Omaha Steaks calm the searchbar you type
in Pakman PA KMA n that's what you need
to do to get the family grill
for the discounted rate of $49.99